[تصفيق]
روبرت كندي جونير ابن المدعي العام الذي
اغتيل في الستينات الروبرت كندي وابنه اخي
الرئيس جون كندي وعمه كان السنه كندي
ينحدر من اشهر العائلات الامريكيه عرقه
وهي عائلته كندي يريد اعاده دور الاسره
التي لعبت دورا مهما في الحياه السياسيه
الامريكيه من اوسع الابواب ويطمح للوصول
الى هنا الى البيت الابيض في هذا المكان
حكم الشاب الوسيم جون اف كندي الولايات
المتحده لكن حكمه لم يدم طويلا فقد اغتيل
عام
1963 وبعده اقتل اخوه روبرت وهو روبوت
جونيور يعود مره اخرى يعلن الترشح ويريد
ان يعود بنا بالذاكره الى عهد تو يا سابقا
روبرت كندي يتحدى الرئيس الديمقراطي جو
بايدن الذي لم يعلن بعد ترشحها الرسمي
لولايه ثانيه كاندي هو محامي شرس يدافع عن
البيئه وهو معروف بمعارضته الشديده
لاستخدام اللقاحات وهي قضيه سجال عرضته
لانتقادات كثيره من الجناح التقليدي
والمحافظ في الحزب الديمقراطي
لا اعتقد ان روبرت كندي لابن سيقطع شوطا
كبيرا في عمليه الترشيح للانتخابات ليس
عليه فقط مواجهه الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
بل عليه ايضا مواجهه حقيقه ان الكثير من
الديمقراطيين يتساءلون ان كان ديمقراطيا
بدرجه كافيه الافكار التي تحدث عنها كثيره
في السنوات الماضيه تتضمن رفضا اللقاح
فيروس كورونا وهذا ليس موقفا شائعا بين
الديمقراطيين
فرص كندي في الوصول للبيت الابيض ضئيله ان
لم تكن معدومه لكن التحدي للرئيس بايدن قد
يفتح الباب لمرشحين اخرين وخصوصا وان
الكثير من علامات الاستفهام تدور حول
تقدمه في العمر وصحته العقليه واحتفاضه
بنائبه الرئيس كاملا هاريس كمرشحه معه
جميعها امور تقلق الديمقراطيين الذين
يحمسون لكن لم ينتقدوا الرئيس بايدن في
العالم بعد نادي البلبيسي العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات